ASSEMBLY MEMBER F. NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF HARM THE SERGEANTS
AT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE
CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG. FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
ESTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEAD
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN-
SUSHI NAZARIAN QUINN O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
MARK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERTS RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEEN
MELENDEZ THE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. YEAH A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM USED THEIR
CONSCIENCE YOUR MOM USED THEIR.
IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. I'M
NOT A GOD. BLESS US THAT WE MAY
LIVE IN PEACE AND HARMONY. AND
REMAIN STEADFAST IN THE LOVE WE
SHOW EACH OTHER. TAKE US AWAY
FROM EVERY TEMPTATION. WHETHER
PHYSICAL MENTAL OR SPIRITUAL.
GOD HELP US TO LIVE ACCORDING
TO YOUR COMMANDMENTS. I'M
LIVING THIS LIFE WITH PEACE AND
REPENTANCE IN OUR HEARTS. FOR
YOU ARE THE GOD OF HOPE AND
LOVE. AND WE KNOW NO ONE BUT
YOU I MEAN. THANK YOU
REMANUFACTURE WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. READY SALUTE PLEDGE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES. ZERO AND-
REMEMBER THAT PROBLEM THANK YOU
YOU MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY TUMOR
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE USING
THE MINUTE SEVENTY M. THE
HONORABLE FRANK BIGELOW SOME
THE RIVER FOR THE DISTURBANCE
OUTINGS YOU FOLKS PROGRAM THE
DEATHS REFLECTIVITY WOMAN
READING FOLLOWING A PLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA ABOUT.
DAVIS FOR THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION
THEN PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. PROVING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES WE HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER IS. DALY FRAZIER AND
PARK AT FOR MEDICAL LEAVE AND
I'M PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WITH. MEMBERS YESTERDAY
WITH CARLOS THE ABBOUD WAS
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND TOMORROW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AND LACKEY HERE BIRTHDAY
ELEVEN PASSED. HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MR IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED HER
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER OUR REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHAU
KILEY AND GRAY TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. NOW SPEAKER ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PRINT THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STATE TO THE STATE
MESSAGE AS AN APPENDIX TO THE
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE FILE ITEM ONE
WILL BE PASSED IN ROUTINE.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS TWO AND
THREE DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
AND THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SECOND A CONTENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
RELATIVE TO GIRL SCOUTS OF THE
USA. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE IN THE CAN. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF IT. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY
VOTE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDARS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINDER OF THE CONTENT
CALENDAR. RESOLUTION.
THIRTY
FOUR FIVE FIFTY EIGHT ZERO
ZERO. MEMBERS. MEMBERS. ASK FOR
YOUR ATTENTION. TODAY IS
SENATOR LACKS PALM LOGGERS LAST
DAY WITH US ON THE ASSEMBLY FOR.
SHE WILL BECOME A SENATOR LATER
TODAY. SO I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING. I WILL BEGIN BY
THINKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM
AUGER WE CAN SAY THAT FOR A FEW
MORE HOURS. EDIBLE SERVICE IN
THIS BODY HAVE BEEN HONORED TO
SERVE WITH YOU AND YOU HAVE
MADE US BETTER AND STRONGER.
AND I KNOW OUR LOSSES THE
SENATE GAINS THAT WE WISH YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE HOUSE. MATT
MATURITY LEADER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SO MUCH THANK YOU
SYDNEY WE ARE GOING TO MISS YOU
SO MUCH HERE YOU HAVE BEEN A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR THE VERY
COMMUNITIES WE REPRESENT YOUR
FOUGHT THE GOOD FIGHT AND I
KNOW THAT ALTHOUGH WE'RE GOING
TO MISS YOU ADJUSTERS THAT ARE.
OUR PRESIDING OFFICER SPEAK
MADAM SPEAKER SAID THAT WE WILL
REDUCE OUR LOSS IT'S A SENATE'S
GAME BUT I KNOW THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WATCH YOU ON YOUR
TWITTER PAGE- THAT THOSE ARE
ALWAYS A LOT OF FUN. BUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR FIGHTING FOR
EQUITY FOR OUR PEOPLE OF COLOR
FOR WOMEN. YOUR VOICE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND TO SO
MANY OF US FOLLOW YOU AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO CALL YOU IN
THE SENATE THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR ALL YOU DO. MISTER
GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT MY
MICROPHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM SPEAKER. LET ME
JUST SIMPLY SAY TO SYDNEY MY
LITTLE SISTER- WE'RE GOING TO
MISS YOU- MISLEAD DEEPLY ON
THIS FLOOR- EVERY TIME THAT YOU
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE- WE KNOW
THERE'S A FIGHT WE KNOW THERE'S
A LINE THERE'S A TIGER IN YOU.
REPRESENTING YOUR DISTRICT YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY TENACIOUS.
TENACIOUS YOU ARE A FIGHTER YOU
BELONG ON THIS FLOOR YOU BELONG
IN THIS CAPITAL IT IS NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND. THAT YOU BELONG- IN
LEADERSHIP AND YOU HAVE
CERTAINLY EXHIBIT AT THAT KIND
OF FIGHT THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP SINCE THE MOMENT YOU
WERE ELECTED- TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY. AND I KNOW
THAT- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO LOSE A COLLEAGUE WE'RE JUST
GOING TO. SEE SOMEONE THAT WE
CAN CONNECT WITH ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE HOUSE FIGHTING FOR
DIGNITY RESPECT FOR WORKING
FAMILIES FOR THE
DISENFRANCHISED UNDER SIR. YOU
WILL GO THERE AS A ROLLING LINE
IN THE STATE SENATE I'M JUST
HAPPY TO KNOW YOU TO HAPPY TO
SERVE WITH YOU ON THIS FLOOR
AND LET ME SIMPLY CLOSE BY
SAYING THIS I KNOW. THAT THE
BEST IS STILL YET TO COME THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH MY SISTER. MR
HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU AYE I WOULD JUST JOIN WITH.
MY COLLEAGUES AND RECOGNIZING
YOUR- TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP OF
FRIENDSHIP BUT I WAS JUST
SITTING HERE AND I THINK TO
MYSELF- THOSE TWO DEATHS.
SURPRISINGLY ARE LOW WE LOST DR
WEBER AND NOW YOU SO WERE YOU
GUYS TALKING ABOUT ALL THIS
TIME WHERE. WE MISSED OUT ON IT
BUT- WE'RE GOING TO MISS YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ALL WITH THE L. A. COUNTY. ARE
CAUCUS- YOU HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB IN BRINGING US
TOGETHER. KEEPING HIS FOCUS
LARGEST CAUCUS IN THIS
BUILDING. AND SO WE CHECK THAT
WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO FOCUS AND STRATEGIZING
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORKING
WITH UNICEF. GRADUATIONS. MISS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I IN
NO WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS SO I
WAS UP IN MY OFFICE AND I JUST
RAN DOWN THE STAIRS A LITTLE
OUT OF BREATH BUT- YOU KNOW HOW
I FEEL I'M SO PROUD OF YOU AND
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S SAD TO
KNOW THAT I WILL BE THE ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN AND
YOU'LL BE THE ONLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN THERE. BUT HE
SAID SOMETHING THE OTHER DAY
AND I WANT TO DISPUTE IT. YOU
SAID OUR SHOULDERS AREN'T
STRONG ENOUGH. AND THEY ARE.
AND I KNOW YOURS ARE FOR SURE.
I HAVE WATCHED YOU FIGHT ON THE
FLOOR I HAVE WATCHED YOU FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE. WE WILL ALWAYS BE
THE ONLY WOMEN IN THESE TWO
HOUSES I KNOW IT. BUT UNTIL IT
THERE IS MORE PARITY. I KNOW
YOU'VE GOT US OVER IN THE
SENATE. AS A BLACK WOMAN. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING YOU TO
CONTINUE TO RISE. AND I COULD
LOOK LOVE THE IDEA THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE SISTERS ON EITHER
SIDE. SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. SYDNEY MY
SISTER TO THE WEST OF ME. MY
SISTER THAT'S ALL PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH ME AND MY REAL SYSTEM TO
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE. I AM SO GLAD
YOU'LL BE OVER ON THE OTHER
SIDE AND I HOPE TO GOD THEY
HAVE THE WISDOM TO PUT YOU ON
PUBLIC SAFETY LIKE YOU WERE ON
HERE SHE CAN STOP ALL THOSE BAD
SENATE BILLS COMING MY WAY
EVERY YEAR. SO WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER. EVEN BETTER NOW
BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE A SPY ON
THE OTHER SIDE. WE HAVE
SOMEBODY UNDERSTANDS THE WAY WE
THINK. BUT MOST IMPORTANT WE
HAVE SOMEBODY THAT ACTUALLY
CARES. ABOUT PEOPLE. I MEAN ALL
PEOPLE. A LOT OF TIMES WEEK
WE'D GO INTO DIFFERENT BOXES.
BUT I KNOW. YOU CARE ABOUT
EVERYONE. AND WHEN YOU STAND UP
AND YOU STAND UP ON THE OTHER
SIDE. I KNOW IT'S A IT'S FROM
YOUR HEART. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS SOMETIMES
SORELY MISSED AROUND HERE. THAT
WE DON'T GET THINGS FROM THE
HEART. AND SOME OF THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN FROM YOUR NEIGHBOR DR
WEBER WHO WOULD GET ON HIS
FLOOR. AND WE KNEW SHE SHE
SPOKE FROM THE HEART. MAYBE
THAT'S WHY YOU TO REPAIR.
BECAUSE YOU TWO ARE SO MUCH
ALIKE. IF YOU BOTH THE
FIGHTERS. AND THAT'S WHY THIS
FLOOR IS LOST SO MUCH. FROM YOU
TO WOMEN DO YOU TO BLACK WOMEN.
LEAVING THIS HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
BUT SHE'S GOING TO DO GREAT
THINGS IN. THAT SECTOR STATE.
AND YOU RENT DO EXCEPTIONAL
THINGS ON THE SENATE SIDE. SO I
CONGRATULATE YOU AND IT'S- I'M
IN MISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MISCON
LONGER THE MIKE IS YOURS IF YOU
LIKE IF THE IF YOU WERE. WELL.
I JUST WANT. TO THANK THIS. FOR
WELCOMING ME. SLIGHTLY OVER TWO
YEARS AGO I CAME IN IN THE
MIDDLE OF SESSION WHEN. PEOPLE
HAD BILLS AND THEY WERE BEING
HEARD IN COMMITTEES SENT. HERE
WAS THIS PERSON WITH A.
PROBABLY VERY STRANGE AND-
RIGID UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WAS
A GOOD BILL IN WHAT WAS A BAD
BILL WHO. INITIALLY HAD A VERY.
WEIRD LIKING TO THE RED BUTTON.
I'M. BUT YOU ALL WERE SO
GRACIOUS TO ME. AND WELCOMING
ME. AND EDUCATING ME ABOUT THE
UNIQUENESS OF THE FLOOR AND
THIS BODY AND IT WASN'T JUST
DEMOCRATS. IT WAS REPUBLICAN.
IT WASN'T JUST MAN. IT WAS ALSO
THE WOMEN ALTHOUGH I SAID THAT
IN REVERSE. IT WASN'T JUST
MEMBERS FROM THE BLACK CAUCUS.
BUT FROM ALL OF THE IDENTITY
CAUCUSES. WHO MAYBE THOUGHT
THAT THEY HAD A PARTNER IN ME
AND IN MY VOICE. AND I JUST
HOPE. THAT I HAVE PROVEN. TO
EACH OF YOU THAT I AM A PARTNER.
IN TRUTH IN EQUITY AND FAIRNESS
IN DISCUSSION IN DEBATE AND IN
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
JUDGMENT. AND WITHOUT
POLARIZATION. I THINK WE GET
MORE. WHEN WE WORK FOR
CONSENSUS. I THINK WE GET MORE.
WHEN WE BUILD COALITIONS. I
THINK WE GET MORE WHEN WE AGREE
TO DISAGREE. ON POLICY BUT WHEN
WE STILL TREAT PEOPLE AND
THEY'RE DISTRICTS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND THEIR VALUE.
WITH DIGNITY. THAT IS WHAT THIS
BODY IS ABOUT. AND THAT IS WHAT
CALIFORNIA DESERT. LEGISLATORS
WHO CREATE POLICY. THINKING
ABOUT THE BEST OF WHAT THE
STATE CAN BE. AND HOW ARE
DISTINCTIVE. AND UNIQUE VOICES
CAN WE'VE TOGETHER INTO
SOMETHING THAT IS DIGNIFIED AND
PROGRESSIVE. MOVING TOWARDS
PROGRESS FOR ALL. SO I FEEL
ONCE AGAIN LIKE A TRANSFER
STUDENT. POPPING OUT. IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SESSION BUT I
WILL NOT FORGET YOU ALL. I
LEARNED MY TRADE HERE ON THIS
FLOOR. WITH SO MANY OF YOU WHO
I CONSIDER FRIENDS. DEEP
PERSONAL FRIENDS. THAT I
LEARNED FROM. WHO GUIDE ME WHO
CHALLENGED ME AND I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL KNOW. THAT I WILL GO
TO THE SENATE SIDE WITH THE
DEEP COMPASSION. FOR YOUR IDEAS
AND YOUR BILLS. AND YOUR
DESIRES TO BRING SOMETHING BACK
TO YOUR DISTRICTS IN A WAY THAT
MAKE THEM BETTER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU COMMA- I DON'T
SPEAK FOR ALL OF US WHEN I SAY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP.
MEMBERS
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK
THAT YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INTERMINABLY MISTER
CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR DESK YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SO I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOROTHY DHEA. A FRIEND AND A
LONGTIME TRUSTEE IN THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHO UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY FROM CULVER
NINETEEN. DOOR GREW UP IN EAST
LA WITH HER PARENTS BOTH
IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO HERMAN'S
SWADDLE AND SO LEAD SWADDLE.
AND SISTER SALON G. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM BISHOP CANADIAN
HIGH SCHOOL SHE WORKED AS A
SECRETARY FOR THE ARCHITECTURAL
FIRM BARKER IN OUGHT AND BECAME
A HOMEMAKER AFTER MARRYING
ALTHEA IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX.
BUT THE SECRETARIAL SKILLS
NEVER LEFT AND DECADES LATER
SHE TOLD NOTES AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS AND SHORTHAND. A SELF
DESCRIBED PTA MOM SHE
SUCCESSFULLY RAN FOR OFFICE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. HE
SERVED FIVE TERMS THE LAST
DEVOTED TO MAJOR RENOVATIONS AT
ALHAMBRA HIGH WITH THE LIBRARY
WAS NAMED IN HER HONOR. DORA
WAS A FREQUENT DEFENDER OF ARTS
EDUCATION OPPOSING PROPOSALS TO
CUT BACK FUNDING ON INSTRUCTION
FOR MUSIC AND VISUAL ARTS-
CAMPAIGN SLOGAN CAME FROM AN
INSPIRATION MESSAGE YOU HAD
SEEN PAINTED ON A WALL DURING A
FAMILY VACATION IN MEXICO.
WHICH TRANSLATES FROM SPANISH
INTO ENGLISH HOUSE TO LOVE A
CHILD IS TO EDUCATE A CHILD. IT
IS NOT SURPRISING THAT MANY OF
HER CHILDREN'S FRIENDS CALL
DOOR. MOM ALSO LAST YEAR HER
HUSBAND DIED IN OCTOBER OF
NATURAL CAUSES AND HER ELDEST
SON DANIEL DIED IN MARCH
FOLLOWING A STROKE. DOOR IS
SURVIVED BY DAUGHTER LISA AND
SON STEVE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOROTHY IDEA. I THINK THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY ASKED THESE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THIS
SESSION IN THE MEMORY OF PAUL
ANTHONY HAYES JUNIOR. PAUL
SPENT HIS LIFE IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION HE ATTENDED
VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND WENT ON
TO ATTEND SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY WHERE HE GREW UP AND
WHERE HE GRADUATED WITH A
DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING. HE
SPENT HIS CAREER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AS
A PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER. PAUL
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
COAST GUARD. AND WAS STATIONED
IN COOS BAY OREGON. ALTHOUGH I
SHOULD SAY THAT THIS IT DID NOT
AFFECT HIS LOYALTY HAS A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SPORTS
TEAMS. INCLUDING THE RAIDERS AS
GIANTS FORTY NINERS AND
WARRIORS I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST TO THIS HAVING WATCHED-
SOME FORTY NINERS GAMES WITH
THEM. I AT FIRST GOT TO KNOW
PAUL WHEN I- RECOGNIZED HIS
WIFE ROSARIO AS MY FIRST
HONOREE- FOR WOMAN OF THE YEAR
THEY HAD RECENTLY STARTED-
CENTER STREET TALK URREA- WHICH
HAS INCREDIBLE TACOS BUT HAD.
BECOME JUST THIS. INSTITUTION
FULSOME ALMOST RIGHT AWAY AND
ROZARIO WAS SCH. AN AMAZING
PART OF THE FULL SOME COMMUNITY
YOU KNOW SHE WAS IN ROAD RAGE
IS THE CHAMBER IN COUNTLESS
OTHER WAYS- AND JACKIE WAS JUST
ELECTED TO THE FULL SOME CITY
COUNCIL- BUT SHE AND- PAUL WERE
JUST SUCH. AN INCREDIBLE TEAM.
AND EVERYTHING THEY DID YOU
KNOW THEY LIT UP THE WHOLE CITY
OF FOLSOM MADE THE COMMUNITY A
BETTER PLACE. NOT JUST THROUGH
THEIR- THEIR ACTS IN THEIR
DEEDS IN THEIR GENEROSITY- BUT
JUST THROUGH THE KINDNESS THAT
THEY BROUGHT. TO EVERY
INTERACTION. AND PAUL WAS VERY
SPECIAL IN THIS RESPECT EVERY
ONCE IN AWHILE YOU MEET SOMEONE
WHO YOU KNOW JUST. BY TALKING
TO THEM YOU JUST GET A SENSE OF
HOW GOOD AND TRUE- THEIR HEART
IS AND- AND THAT WAS PAUL I
MEAN HE JUST EXUDED. WARMTH AND
KINDNESS AND CARING. AND HE-
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY ON
FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH AFTER A SIX
AND A HALF YEAR BATTLE. WITH
CANCER AND IT'S A LOSS THAT IS.
DEEPLY DEEPLY FELL- BY THE
ENTIRE CITY OF FOLSOM AND SO
MANY PEOPLE- WHO YOU KNOW I
MYSELF INCLUDED. WHO ARE BETTER
FOR HAVING HAVING KNOWN PAUL-
HE SURVIVED BY ROSARIO AS WELL
AS- HIS STEP SON. YOU BONNIE
CHAMBERLAIN AND GRANDSONS
ANTONIO LEO AND. DISTEFANO
CHAMBERLAIN MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
ASK THAT THE CALL. STATE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED SESSION IN
THE MEMORY OF PAUL HAYES. THANK
YOU MISTER KILEY MR GRAY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR NUMBER
TO MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE TWENTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. TWO GERMAN
IN THE MEMORY OF A BELOVED LOS
BATTLES COMMUNITY LEADER
COLLEEN MENIFEE. WE LOST
COLLEEN AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
SIX ON FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH.
SHE WAS BORN JANUARY ELEVENTH
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IN THE
SKOKIE OKLAHOMA. SHE SPENT HER
CHILDHOOD LIVING ALL VER THE
CENTRAL WESTERN UNITED STATES
DUE TO HER FATHER'S WORK WITH
THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION. HER
FAMILY EVENTUALLY SETTLED IN
LOS BANOS WHERE SHE HAPPILY
LIVE FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE.
CALLING GRADUATED WITH A DEGREE
IN GEOGRAPHY FROM UCSB WHERE
SHE ALSO MET HER HUSBAND JERRY.
COLLEEN AND JERRY WENT ON TO
RAISE THREE WONDERFUL CHILDREN
SCOTT CEREN STEVEN. WELL C<c.cyan>G</c>
IS PROBABLY BEST KNOWN FOR THE
TWENTY FOUR YEARS SHE SPENT ON
THE LOS BANOS SCHOOL BOARD. SHE
DEMONSTRATED A SELFLESS
DEDICATION TO COMMUNITY SERVICE
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE. FROM
WORKING EVERYDAY WITH JERRY AT
THE VETERINARY HOSPITAL TO OUR
ADVOCACY FOR THE ARTS LITERACY
AND STEWARDSHIP. COLLEEN'S
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY WAS
EVIDENT EVERYWHERE SHE WENT.
SHE TRULY LEFT AN INDELIBLE
MARK ON EVERYONE WHO WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO KNOW HER INCLUDING ME.
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN HONORING
COLLEEN'S LEGACY IN ADJOURNING
IN MEMORY OF THIS WONDERFUL AND
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT WHO
BROUGHT JOY AND LIGHT TO SO
MANY. THANK YOU MISTER GRAY
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DEATHLY PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED DURING A
MEMORY WE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULES AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
MARCH TWELFTH FLOOR SESSION AND
NO TRACKING SESSION MONDAY
MARCH FIFTEENTH FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED ON MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
THIS CARILLO MOVES AND MISTER
MATHIS SECOND THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MARCH FIFTEENTH AT ONE PM.